all right folks welcome uh we're a few
minutes late but we're uh we're good to
go we do have a quorum we have one
measure to hear today
uh which is uh SB
103 but as is the custom in this
committee we usually start with a uh
Pledge of Allegiance and we have a uh
another member welcome representative
Hartley
we're very glad you're here almost as
glad as we were to see representative
Siebert that
so we will um
we will look to representative
Hartley to lead us in the pledge in a
few moments as soon as we all get
settled
not every committee does the Pledge but
I know representative baldacero made
that part of the routine here
and it's a tradition there's a place for
tradition I think in representative
Levitt welcome great to see you
you're 100 or close to 100 percent
I heard
you could be the cleric if we were stuck
uh
representatively we good to go
okay stand by
e
liberty and justice for all
right we'll get right to it uh
introducing the bill uh we're going to
the chair recognizes uh Grant bossy
from
currently uh from the Senate side is
that correct that is correct good
morning chairman moffatt members of the
state
there we go
good morning and uh thank you I am Grant
bossy from the New Hampshire Senate here
to introduce Senate Bill 103 on behalf
of Senator Rebecca Perkins who is my
Senator and also the prime sponsor of
the bill
SB 103 came out of a request from a
constituent to recognize the historic
importance of the raid on Fort William
and Mary now known as Fort Constitution
let me take you back December 13th
1774 Paul Revere wrote out of Boston to
warn the Colonials that the British are
coming the British are coming
but this was four months before his
famous ride to Lexington and Concord
Massachusetts his first ride was
actually to Portsmouth New Hampshire he
carried news that British ships were on
the way to secure the powder
at Fort William and Mary in Newcastle
for the king's use keeping it from the
Revolutionary colonists for the Brewing
American Revolution
at noon on December 14th a crowd of 400
Colonials from Portsmouth rye and
Newcastle marched on the fort which was
guarded by a lone British captain and
just five Redcoats there was a brief
exchange of gunfire some minor injuries
and the granite Staters overwhelmed The
Garrison
these were the first shots of the
American Revolution throughout the day
on the 14th and the 15th the conquerors
made off with the military stores
eventually Distributing nearly a hundred
barrels of gunpowder across New
Hampshire and this proved vital in the
Revolutionary battles to come they
actually left the fort before the
British reinforcements could arrive
in 1791 the fort was renamed Fort
Constitution and it actually remained in
service as part of our coastal defense
through 1948. it's currently a state
Historic Site
SB 103 was introduced uh as a
designation day it would have named
December 14th and 15th as Fort
Constitution days now knowing that the
house has been well let's say highly
skeptical of adding additional days to
our annual calendar Senator Bradley
suggested that we rework the bill to
commemorate the 250th anniversary of the
raid on Fort William and Mary which is
coming up quickly next year
this legislature has already set up a
sester centennial commission it's a new
word for me sesters Centennial means
250th I'm I'm just old enough to
remember the bicentennial and I know
some of you aren't old enough to
remember the bicentennial so the sister
centennials commission would commemorate
the American Revolution and the
Declaration of Independence
this group is currently tasked with
planning an event for July 4th 2026 SB
103 asked that the commission also
marked New Hampshire's vital role in the
beginning of our fight for independence
this would give the commission a window
of 19 months from December 2024 all the
way through July 2026 for Education
Outreach and events commemorating the
American res Revolution
there is a drafting error in the bill as
amended this is my fault on line 14 It
should read December 14 2024.
I believe it says 2026. so the idea is
that we would Mark Fort constitute Fort
William and Mary in December 2024 and
hold events all the way up through the
250th of the signing of the Declaration
uh in July 2026. SB 103 would highlight
New Hampshire's role in the American
Revolution first in the nation if you
will and help us Mark its importance
from the first shots fired in Newcastle
all the way to the signing of the
Declaration in Philadelphia Senator
Perkins quoka thanks you for your
consideration and your support of Senate
bill 103.
uh thank you Mr blossey so looking at
the uh the date correction online I'm
looking at line 26 uh it says December
14 2024 or 2026 and you're explaining it
should say 2024 yes
so the actual uh measure in front of us
uh technically needs to be amended yes
okay
um
that's something that could probably
happen uh very quickly uh if if we uh is
that something that you could check with
uh
yeah if we could uh
have that uh Amendment
um made uh
through OLS however they work so we
could uh if you could help us to effort
that so that we can we can vote on the
right date
that would be uh that would be great so
while
uh steyer is working that I there are
perhaps some questions I have one or two
uh Mr bossy
um on line six it refers to the first
line six and seven the first shots fired
now I I know you're a history guy
and famously uh April 19 1775 The Shot
Heard the shot heard around the world uh
took place in Lexington so I want to get
my head around this
um so the measure we're looking at
specifically mentions as amended shot
the first shots fired
so we know shots were fired during this
action
yes
uh I'll give myself a follow-up and says
the shots were not heard around the
world and that's what we're trying to
fix they may be heard around the world
this community Lexington and Concord had
a better publicist in Longfellow who
wrote the famous poem
um about the midnight ride of Paul
Revere so Massachusetts has gotten
better press on this uh we're hoping to
fix this and let people know that the
first shots of the American Revolution
were actually on Newcastle
so with regard to those first shots
which may be very significant because
they're in the language of the measure
and uh which is why I want to
confirm that there were shots fired
there were no casualties is that correct
no I believe there were minor injuries
there were no deaths
okay the the British captain seeing
himself greatly outnumbered something
like 80 to one
um briefly resisted there's a musket
fire and then he surrendered The
Garrison
okay and um again I
want to uh while we're waiting for uh
the amendment to hopefully come back to
us on on line 26.
um
and I know we have another speaker
coming up who maybe Can Shed light on
this if the confronting shots were fired
uh nobody was killed or you use term
injuries
um
wounds casualties I'm not I'm not sure
if the wounds were as a result of a
musket shot or another injury but there
were there were some
um minor injuries uh no casualties
you also you also mentioned Paul Revere
and I I know I knew Paul Revere was
involved with alerting people uh so
could you touch on him again real quick
so uh what was his role in this uh
you already touched on that yeah well it
was similar to what happened uh in
Lexington and Concord and that he heard
he his job was to uh tell people about
the intelligence that they had learned
and I don't know how that the uh Royal
Navy was was sending a ship to reinforce
the Garrison at Fort William and Mary uh
to secure the gunpowder that's really
what the military significance of this
was the gunpowder that was on the island
um the Colonials didn't have much of a
Navy so the fact that the British held
the fort itself was not of military
significance it was the military stores
uh which were in short supply and uh the
Colonials I'm not sure how heard that
the British were going to reinforce this
Garrison and they thought well we should
take that gunpowder now while it's
lightly defended and they're only as we
said six Redcoats there
um so Paul Revere Road North out of
Boston Road up to Portsmouth the on the
13th on the 14th 400 people got together
marched on the fort took the fort and
then over the next two days got the
gunpowder out and it was distributed uh
on the fourth uh the website maintained
by the uh state division of natural and
cultural resources uh talks about the
significance of that gunpowder and how
it was just the barrels were distributed
across the state for use by the
Revolutionary forces so this is
fascinating history in the parallels to
Lexington and Concord are
beyond the shots fired Sean heard shots
heard around the world Paul Revere again
writing you just said that he wrote up
from Boston that that's a pretty good
ride uh
he had just one horse he I believe he
just wrote up on one hand I think he
wrote up himself I could be wrong on
that but that the the account I heard
was that he he wrote up to tell the
people in Portsmouth that something was
happening and then they rallied together
uh with people from the surrounding
towns Rye Newcastle Portsmouth and
marched on the fort
okay uh other questions for Mr bossy
who's introducing the bill for Senator
Cuoco
uh represent Rollins
yeah I'm a bit a bit of a history buff
just out of curiosity all right just to
know more about the Battle whatever were
the British taken prisoner or were they
left at the Fort I believe they were let
held and then released when the
Colonials left I could be wrong and and
one of the things this uh commission
would do is uh help inform me and you
and all of us about what actually
happened awesome thank you
other questions
representative minion
oh is pointing to uh representative the
representative from Pentacle yeah having
fought in the Revolutionary I thought
I'd tell you my personal eyewitness
account
um actually uh General Gage's wife was
an American and there's some speculation
she was actually a spy for the committee
of safety in Boston and learned that the
general was sending troops to ship to
Portsmouth the seas in reinforce Fort
William Mary and the committee and
safety of Boston heard about it and had
Revere leave on December 13th it was a
cold and snowy night and ride to
Portsmouth to warn them they've got to
get the powder out of there because
there's a moratorium on colonists
getting particles of the turmoil that
was taking place between the United
States and England and uh it was only
six British soldiers defending the fort
and the captain in charge of the fort
resisted of first and he was hit with a
musket over the head and received some
injuries and they took the powder took
it up the river on a gundalo to Durham
that's where it was held in the news
that Bunker Hill later on and
um just the one added factors retired
U.S Marshal the sheriff of Rockingham
County was audited by uh Governor
Wentworth to get a posse and seize those
that did this and also the powder
and that was John Parker who John was
the Uncle John Parker Hale and uh
Sheriff Parker went back to the governor
and said I'm sorry Mr Governor I can't
find anybody a little serving my Posse
and uh Mr Parker was as Sheriff was the
first one to read the New Hampshire uh
Declaration of Independence here in New
Hampshire at the State House in
Portsmouth and became the first U.S
Marshal for New Hampshire appointed by
President Washington
and uh and I enjoyed my children Judy
with the colonial forces
excellent history representative thank
you for sharing that and uh there was no
question for the for
well thank you for that
thank you Mr Speaker I'll tell Senator
Carson I'm sure the sister Centennial
commission would be calling on you uh in
the next year I was appointed and then
the speaker's office realized the
appointed two Democrats and I deferred
to the other Democrat who's uh
much better to serve in that position so
but I'll be doing whatever I can as a
layperson thank you so the gentleman
from Penacook has pointed out uh that uh
his knowledge a Redco was conked in the
head with a musket so that there's
certainly an injury there but he
mentioned the gunpowder and being
usually a Bunker Hill
and very significantly John Stark is is
uh representative shartliff knows uh
played a New Hampshire troops under John
Stark Colonel at the time John Stark
played a very significant role at Bunker
Hill
so uh my question to
either a view who have some knowledge of
this
um
the representative from Penacook said
that the gunpowder from this action was
used at Bunker Hill uh by the New
Hampshire troops is that fair to say uh
uh I'll I'm supposed to ask you so uh
I I would refer to the speaker on this
one if he has to know
yeah the gunpowder was distributed to
communities around the Portsmouth area
and when Bunker Hill
happened in the militia was called out
to support actually they called out
earlier for what happened in Lexington
and Concord and then they stayed in Camp
in Boston and it was the New Hampshire
militia that used that powder at Bunker
Hill
and I and I would suggest that this bill
would help
um frame that uh the sister Centennial
commission right now has a fairly broad
mandate to look at whatever aspects of
the Revolution it wants in a specific
mandate to have an event pegged to the
250th of the signing of the Declaration
of Independence on July 4th this bill
would give it a second uh Benchmark at
the beginning of the Revolution and I
think would do a good job of focusing on
New Hampshire's vital role in the
revolution the fact that it started in
Newcastle and then over the next 17
months we could Mark other events in the
revolution and New Hampshire's role in
them leading up of course to
Independence Hall in Philadelphia
yes uh
yes
okay
I would also like to add that uh
December 14 2024 is a Saturday
um and I would anticipate a weekend of
events uh in Portsmouth and Newcastle on
the 14th and the 15th uh to commemorate
this I think it will work out very well
okay thank you Mr bossy I had a message
from a former representative former
member of this committee with regard to
the suster Centennial commission and if
that commission is has been meeting as
as it was uh intended to do are you uh
it has not been very active I think this
would help kick-start them and I I know
there was some confusion on who was
serving and I think this would help get
them back together I know Senator Carson
is anxious to to get this going sure
okay thank you for that other questions
Cena thank you Mr bossy for introducing
this uh next we have representative
Timothy Horrigan
who asked for three minutes and we can
give you more than that if you need that
representative
I'm sure I'll use it more than that but
um I'll try I'll try to be brief some
representative Timothy Horgan from
Stratford County District 10 which is
the town of Durham which is where the
gundalo was parked in it's not the same
gundalo that you can see on an adverse
point but very similar um and uh
and I yeah see uh first of all I did
notice the uh date and I thought maybe
that was deliberate because the uh
the commission has gone off to a really
slow start
um which
um
I suppose lots of things are still
getting off the slow starts these days
but so 2024 is a better day to uh
yeah that's the 200th anniversary of the
actual incident which is a very key
incident in the American Revolution and
also I think ironically if I recall
correctly the only time there was
actually like uh
actioned on New Hampshire soil that our
troops
fought in the revolution
um a lot of other places but that was
the only time we had actual like armed
conflict with us in the British right
here on the New Hampshire in New
Hampshire and um
so yeah the uh
strictly speaking it's unnecessary this
is like one of the things that I we I
assume the commission will be doing and
it's it it has not been very active it
met
well the governor signed it and signed
it into law I was just looking at dock
it I think it was April 11 2022. he had
a ceremonial signing which I found out
about reading
it was on page three of the union leader
and the nice picture of him with a
couple of ladies from the DAR which uh
which I was pleased to see
um
I would have gone and watched them
signed with the lady from the dir had I
known about it in advance and they did
um so they had an organizational meeting
in December and actually on the website
the rep who's listed as a chair was uh
um a rep who's now he was an excellent
choice but he's did not run for
reelection he's now no longer remember
the house although I suppose he can
still be a member of the commission so
you uh
the speaker wants to point a different
rep I see uh two
I see two excellent choices uh well more
than two but two especially excellent
choices right here on the other side of
the committee table from me so
um
and um
the reason it was sort of odd that I
became the sponsor of it I sort of back
in back in the summer 2021 I noticed
that no one else had done it and when we
had the bicentennial wheat appointed a
commission a few years out we also have
had the bicentennial of the Constitution
since then and
those are both done um
those were done I think I forget the
exact days but about five or six years
before that and the Crystal Federal
sester attends Centennial commission
which by the way are Senator Gene
Shaheen who at the time was also my
constituent but
um she's a member of so I just felt like
somebody had to introduce the bill so I
decided I went ahead and did it and got
um several several other co-sponsors
including uh representative wall from
Madbury who's currently sitting on the
commission so uh
I uh I certainly uh this is this will be
a certainly a specific uh a specific
event which may spur the commission onto
more on to more more action than it
seems to have been taking
um I mean it hasn't been that long since
the you know it's only been
five months since the organizational
meeting but still you know I would have
anticipated they would have been meeting
much more actively since then and I even
put in a thing of the bill for a fund to
collect donations and so I I would have
expect him to get started a little bit
more quickly than they did but I'm sure
they'll
I'm sure they'll do a good job once they
get going and this may be just a
specific thing that's not that far away
that
they can start working on organizing and
I know there's other uh other
organizations in the Seacoast area and
across the state we would be happy to
have helped make that event that event
happen on on in December 2024 and the
24th 50th anniversary of the uh
the Battle of Fort William and Mary or
whatever you want to call it so as for
the word sister Centennial
um that was what the draft that's what
the federal uh
commissioned this called and that was
what the uh
that was what the drafters wanted to
call it some strange Latin phrase which
I think is one and a half plus it means
experially sister means 2.5 so it's two
and a half times a century so that's
what the sester Centennial is not
necessarily the word I would have chosen
but that's what it is so
um
without be happy to take any questions
um I can't add by the way there were
shirtless I think representative
shurtliff was a little bit too young to
be on active duty in the Revolutionary
War but there were some of his relatives
who who did fight so thanks yeah
yeah
thank you representative this is uh kind
of your this is kind of your lucky day
because uh we're waiting for that
amendment to come back thank you yes and
this is a chance for you to have extra
time okay which uh which I I know you
you can utilize Chris they working that
on that language
okay uh and again there are probably a
few folks watching at home and we what
we're waiting on is an amendment just to
change the uh a housekeeping yes we need
to change a number or a date on the
measure before us
um representative you mentioned the DAR
is a in for folks watching at home or
who watch this later uh I think most of
us know what the DAR is and or
representative Hopson certainly does uh
but could you there's not the dra but
the DAR if you could the daughters well
the dra would be involved in
administering the uh
trust fund which I don't know if anybody
has donated to it but it is there to be
donated but no this is not the
Department of Revenue Administration
this is the Daughters of the American
Revolution so it's uh
and say uh
there's also a sons of the American
Revolution but the DAR is much more
active organizations so it's uh women
whose ancestors
fought in the uh fought in the
Revolution fought on our side of the
Revolution there actually is an
organization of Canada called the
daughters of the Loyalists for those who
are loyal to King George but uh you know
not many members of those here in New
Hampshire but
yeah I mean I guess they're welcome to
help with any if we had a reenactment I
guess they'd be welcome to help recruit
some reenactments for the uh
British Sailors who are on the other
side of the conflict but um no see it
was the Daughters of the American
Revolution
that's what I thought yeah I pretty much
knew Dar was wish for that and to
qualify to be a member of the DAR you
have to certify your or show that you're
a descendant of uh yes of people who
were involved in the revolution yes and
uh
it's probably easier now there's all
those as genealogical databases so I've
like and it's actually they're uh their
directory is actually very valuable
resource if you're any for anybody who's
chasing their ancestry because like uh
the female side of the genealogy is
harder to trace but the dir uh
beginning the 19th century and
continuing to the present day has like
done a very good job of uh you know
recording the history
of of the Revolution and how you know
and how their uh their descendants are
still active today so
okay and uh while we're waiting for that
Amendment um I have one do you would you
believe question representative
thank you uh would you believe that my
fifth great grandfather whose name is
Nathaniel ball senior was the uh first
Secretary of the provincial Congress in
1775 the provincial Congress uh
Forerunner to what became the New
Hampshire legislature of course they
call it the provincial Congress in 1775
because we were a province of a colony
at that time would you believe that I
absolutely would believe it so uh you're
I guess you're what they call a legacy
member so that makes me wonder if I
could be a member of the sons of the
American Revolution you probably could
I've considered it I've actually looked
at many many
applications profess Sons and Daughters
of the revolution from people who are
related to me who lived in the 19th and
20th centuries so I could probably
occasionally consider filling out the
paperwork but uh I haven't gotten around
to it yet and you could certainly do the
same too and the organization still
exists and it's still very active both
the DAR and SAR or
would you believe when I found out that
Nathaniel Blount's senior was my fifth
grade grandfather who was a provincial
Congress leader
um that I went to uh Secretary of State
Gardner when I find this out I said uh
secretary do you know anything he's a
historian of course and I asked if he
knew anything about Nathaniel Ball's
senior and he said he would find out and
so on the very last day of session in
night in 2017 he gave me a folder of
information on Nathaniel Ball's senior
my fifth grade grandfather and
apparently he was among other things on
the committee back then that was tasked
with finding out ways to tax out of
Staters and this was in 1775 so
obviously my fifth grade grandfather was
a man ahead of his time yes would you
believe that oh yes and my final
question uh representative uh would you
believe that Nathaniel Ball's senior's
son who was Nathaniel balls Jr signed up
for stickney's militia in 1777 and
fought with John Stark at Bennington
would you believe that I believe that
well thank you
you mentioned representative wall uh who
is is she one of your constituents as
well or um she well
she still works with us closely they
actually
drew the district line so bad very
Durham where for the first time possibly
since uh Nathaniel Paul Senior and
Junior remembers of legislature Top
members of the part of the same district
but uh yes but she was at the time too
she also apparently had ancestors who
fought in the revolution at Bennington
um yeah she mentioned the stick knees I
think so they there's yes he's he has my
fourth great grandfather signed up for
stickney's militia in July of 1777 the
next month was Bennington so they didn't
have a lot of training at that time
apparently you get your musket and off
you win other questions for the for the
representative
seeing none uh thank you representative
Bill thank you and representative surely
be glad to know this there's shirtless
in my family tree but I haven't been
able to link any of them up to like
just specifically to him yet so but
thank you representative
okay we're waiting on that uh Amendment
and a and going to
uh for the sake of not
uh holding people here for
if we don't need to the amendment the
amending language that we're waiting on
it'll it'll be an amendment that would
have an H after it
um would simply change on line 26
the date of 2026 to 2024.
and
what I would like to do is
have a we would be looking for a motion
and to have a motion
to accept the amending language and then
we could vote on the measure as amended
uh so in anticipation the actual
amendment number hopefully coming from
OLS I'm looking for a motion to
um amend
this measure
and change the date of 2026 to 2024 in
line 26.
member clerk did you get that
representative Levitt made the motion to
change the date of 20 26 to 2024 in line
26 is there a second
representative Seibert seconds uh would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Levitt
would you like would you like speak to
emotion
okay representative receiver
okay
uh so
at this time uh
I would ask the
clerk to call the rule on the proposed
amendment to change the date from 2026
to 2024 and line 26.
here we go
um
go start at the bottom
representative Siebert
uh no O'Neil Lloyd
yes
to the toll yes
lumineer Kerry yes
Boris massmilla yes okay shirtless yes
Manion
yes
Vinnie oh no penny hamanti
gagne Harley
yes
okay Rollins
yes and muffin
yes
I knew that
um
all right
okay
um well thanks for working out
um
okay uh thank you for that motion uh
representative Levitz so we're waiting
on the uh
the actual uh amendment number which uh
we're hoping is coming forth that that
is all that we have today so while we're
waiting on that
um I do want to make a presentation
um to uh one of our members one of our
senior members uh and they'll be
representative massive represent NASA
Miller if you could
watch
uh Carey was committed elsewhere so
um representative the committee would
just like to give you a token of our
appreciation not only for that day but
for all that you've done for for so long
so
there you go that's for you and uh thank
you for your service
all right
our presentation our gift for rep for
the representative from Littleton uh was
purchased at a state-owned facility and
so the uh
that also uh provided a little bit of
revenue for
for New Hampshire I'm going to recess uh
briefly well
um
Christina is checking on the amendment
number and hopefully we can
finish that and do that uh in a proper
fashion as as soon as she gets back so
I'm going to go to a recess for for uh
10 minutes thank you
stressful
folks while we're still in recess
waiting for That official Amendment
um
representative control suggests we get a
photo in representative uh
uh from Durham is here or Christina
maybe could snap that if if we want to
do that now
we should have the amendment in five
minutes don't go away
standby
GMO uh chair Market
uh I like to make a motion to um so that
they need to gavel Us in out of recess
first
okay we are reconvening uh we have a uh
a number for the amendment that we
um or have adopted or adopting uh and
that is
2023-1569 H that is the amendment uh
we've already voted on the language for
this amendment
um
so then we now need to go to voting on
the measure as amended uh Levitt uh
I'll pass chair Moffett thank you okay
uh so
I am looking for a motion now to adopt
the measure as amended reflecting the
the one change in the date from uh 20 26
to 2024
the amendment number again is 1569 h
so I'm looking for a motion to
approve the measure as amended
Representative shirtleff makes the
motion to
uh adopt the amen the measure as amended
SB 103
do we have a second
thank you representative massamila
seconds it uh represent sure love would
you care to speak to your motion
I think uh we've discussed it thoroughly
I think we're all ready for the vote Mr
chairman
thank you any further uh questions or
comment
uh representative P Money
uh thank you Mr chair uh on the um
Amendment
gives the RSE
17-ish calling three Roman numeral nine
as inserted by section two of the bill
by replacing it with the following
um does that is that going to move this
effective date to the next
uh line past that
see you in section two where it says
effective date the Celtic effect Upon A
Passage
okay I'm looking at that
foreign
by section two
that is not what you're reading is is uh
just a description of the amendment
um the location of the the change is on
lines 2627 which is by your next two uh
section two
so that uh
shouldn't have any impact on the wording
of the of the date change
clarification on that
great thank you thank you for that
anything else
if not then the uh if Madam clerk if you
would read the role for the uh motion to
accept the bill as amended
yes
representative ledbet yes representative
Rollins yes representative Moffett
yes
so that is one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve in
favor none of those 12-0 so without
objection we will uh send that on uh
recommend on consent
and that is all that we have uh I want
to thank everybody for being here uh we
needed that quorum to get this done
um we've completed all 17 of our
original measures we have one that's
retained that we'll come back to next
year we had this one from the Senate
which is now done so we should be good
to go for until uh until next year so
thank you uh I think we've had a good
session and appreciate everybody's time
uh and I will uh
end the hearing at this time thank you
I'm Miss chairman uh yes sir yeah now
that we're I guess we're off the Record
now but I do want to thank the chair for
the excellent job you've done in running
this committee and uh decorum yeah uh
the way you've treated the members of
the committee and the people that have
testified you've done an excellent job
I've seen a lot of chairs and you've
done a great job and I just wanted to
compliment you for that
for the one session I've been here I'll
second that
thank you thank you I don't know if it's
still on YouTube but uh thank you very
much for that representative Cheryl I
really appreciate that
and we'll uh see everybody in the big
house
so you've got everything to
um
foreign